[Music]
have you guys heard of this
hilarious story about hilaria baldwin
oh no yeah who's that that's justin
bieber's girlfriend
no so this is alec baldwin's wife oh
so there's so many baldwins sorry wait
who's alec baldwin again
the main baldwin famous one the main
ball dirty rock baldwin
yeah so this is his wife they've been
together they have like
four or five children five children i
think whoa she had four kids
five guys her body's blind so she's a
yoga teacher
she's like a she she's kind of an
influencer she
shares a lot of yoga videos and stuff
and she's a very stretchy person these
are all oh yeah here we go that's a lot
of kids dude i think there's one more
they're cute
man they're all the same age that's
crazy so
it was the one that he yelled at on the
phone i don't know do you remember that
they got the baby
he has such an alec baldwin expression
that is a good bald one
um i don't know he yelled at a baby no
no it was his daughter
on the phone it was like a famous leash
call at the time he's like listen to me
you'll do it
was it him or was it hasselhoff no no is
it well i think hasselhoff has one too
but yeah it was him for sure was it from
a different marriage like another kid
i don't know maybe all right well the
whole story here
is that so they're saying that hilaria
she's actually born hillary
and hilaria yeah hilarious
why was ilaria it is from spain well
she's not yeah so she
she was born here one thing that is
saying that even alec baldwin has said
my
my wife is from spain but she's born in
boston
and so she grew up in boston but
according to her
she grew up in spain as well because her
family would vacation a lot but her
parents
like they have had long careers in the
united states i think she's like fourth
generation bostonian or something
and so like like she's american she grew
up like in a four million dollar
like home yeah and like she grew up very
wealthy and all this stuff and so her
family just
always really loved spain so they would
vacation
ever since she was a baby she would go
to spain i don't know for how long
but according to her she spent a good
chunk of her childhood there
and also in boston and so like
uh ever since she's been with alex she
has been
referred to as from spain and she always
says like you know in spain this is what
we do
and and so she's just coming off and she
also has like an accent
so she speaks spanish yeah she does
speak fluent spanish and she
is teaching her kids spanish and all of
her kids have very spanish names as well
is she of spanish descent she isn't
because she's been to everywhere in
spain because i'm one island away from
having been to all the islands in hawaii
and then i could say i'm kind of
hawaiian
but i have to get to kuai well if you're
into the big island
yeah you have not been to the big island
i have been to the big island no
you do the if you do the cruise though
which my mom has oh that's great if you
do
the island cruise you do every single
item you get to be a
little bit hawaiian just at the end of
the cruise and at the end of the cruise
you could be like this is my aina yeah
you know my mom grew up in hawaii but
she's white and
the first time i went on vacation i was
a kid and that was the first time my dad
went to hawaii too
and they treated us like locals and they
even like some of the tourists took
pictures with me
because they thought they were they were
taking pictures
and then your mom's the real local
because she was born and raised there
well she wasn't born there but she she
was she didn't grow up see that's a
technicality yeah they're like
if you're not born there like you could
move there as a
one week year old baby and grow up there
but they're like you know
you weren't born here she hasn't claimed
local she hasn't tried to do that any of
that but she did grow up there
yeah so the reason why a lot of people
are talking about hilaria right now is
because someone tweeted out
you have to admire hilaria baldwin's
commitment to her decade long grip
where she impersonates a spanish person
spanish accent debut this woman grew up
in massachusetts
so i do have a little compliment is her
accent fake
well people are saying they're fake
i i don't know what is madonna's accent
i think she lived in london for so long
and she's like yeah i'm from spain like
a [ __ ] buster
yeah that'd be like you're have you seen
have you heard her speaking yeah
i'm gonna go espana so like you could
hear it i'm not from spain speak
words it's a different accent i know but
you could hear it right
kind of like okay like you can't hear
the spanish spanish
versus mexican spanish no it's like
saying you has a lisp
you know if someone from the uk is
faking it versus an american doing a
really good uk accent is fake like we
we don't have the trained ear to know if
it's authentic or not
you guys suck there because i could hear
the japanese accents i'd be like you
faking it did you know
margot robbie was faking an american
accent when you watched wolf of wall
street didn't choose
me neither i never know when they're
doing that right and also there's
i don't know jax teller was british
either so i guess i'm lying to you
okay i appreciate you for admitting that
i have a compilation
and i thought mario had a chinese accent
when she spoke japanese but
it's actually a kyoto accent okay that's
too niche
i don't know that one who's who is it
david david's girlfriend fiancee
all right oh i think you said mario i
thought you said mario okay what's the
compilation the compilation is of
her accents and how they change over
time oh
yeah well this isn't this isn't in like
a chronological
order so you just pay attention to the
dates if you really want to know if it's
before or after a certain accident
oh i'm from spain the rain
married is is really nice you know it
feels different
it really feels and she's not even of
spanish heritage
not her heritage but culturally
she does have two cultures she said um i
think
just the fact that it feels different
you know i we like to say husband and
wife a lot yeah
i come husband i say husband where are
you he took me out to
montauk and said that was as close as he
could get to spain
to my family and to rome because we
really like rome as well her family does
live in spain by the way
but her parents are retired and now and
now live in spain so does her brother
have very few ingredients we have
tomatoes we have um
she forgot cucumber cucumbers it's not
easy and i think part of it is that i'm
in shape before i have a baby
and then i stay active she sounds pretty
californian i'm just trying to keep my
circulation going and stretching and
keep my muscle tone up
it was well you know what i i feel like
all of our children were semi
surprises in a good way good surprises
yeah so there's examples it sounds
very american in every like three words
she tries to like spanish it up
that's what it sounds like to me so this
is her explanation
can i guess can i guess because my
mother is from the south
and she like he still kind of has that
kind of like
southern twin twang but if she goes
there and she's like hanging out there
for like a couple
couple weeks it's like [ __ ] at the
tip of her tongue the whole time
and like and like it's reactivated for
like a couple more months and then it
can kind of fade into the back yeah it
happens to me too like when i kick it
with stacy and stuff my freaking chicana
comes out
yeah so are people mad at this because
so the thing is like people
are upset that she is claiming to be of
like
spain like from spain even though she
doesn't have any like actual bloodlines
in spain
just that her family does live there now
and
they're just upset that culturally she
identifies a lot with spain because she
did grow up with it and all that stuff
but people are like no but you can't
impersonate a spanish
so in her in her seven minute
explanation
video that she posted on instagram she
pretty much placed the blame on everyone
else saying like
uh every time i've done an interview i
tell them i let them know like i was
born in boston
like this like i'm from america but i
just grew up in spain and this is why i
have a spanish accent and this is why
like i have like spanish culture in my
life so
so much and that the reporters were put
would purposely
report that she's born in spain from
spain even her
her agency caa in the website it said
that she was born in spain and she was
like i have no control over what other
people are reporting about me but i've
always been completely honest about
where i'm here i have a lot of friends
who grew up internationally like
from japan or here or asia or whatever
right and they go to school there
and then they have a weird accent
because like they learn
english but some of the schools that
they go to it's like
uk style or british style international
or it's american style
and they might swap from school to
school and then so
uh when you hear them speak you're just
like man i've never heard anything like
this
and then some of them might be like
culturally where they grew up at but
then like on that army base
so for example like one of our friends
he grew up in a japanese army base he's
black
but he grew up in little america in
japan
but he feels a connection to japan so
it's it's like when you're international
like that i think
it mixes everything together yeah and
people just they
they need to place people in certain
boxes and when they don't fit in that
box again
that's what i have a problem with it's
just it's like why are you so concerned
with what other people
identify with unless they're they are
taking away opportunities like
is she trying to teach spanish yoga is
that why if she's out here going as a
spanish person this is what i believe
and this is my culture
believe in yeah exactly if she did that
[ __ ]
on spain either she's like she's like
pretty nice she's not trying to write
there's this one post that really rubbed
people the wrong way
after finding out that she's just a
straight up white girl but that has
cultural ties whatever she said she
posted an instagram post and it said
with two blonde
blonde hair blue eye children people at
the park always ask me if i am a nanny
they hear me speak
speaking to my children in spanish and
have been offered so many jobs because
everyone wants to teach the children a
foreign language these days i always
laugh it off and tell them that
if i were not so busy with my two almost
three babies i'd love to come
work for them so here's proof that this
little blah blah blah
but wait isn't spanish white though i
don't i'm confused that's actually what
she said too she's
like treating spanish
people as minorities yeah there's hella
blonde european
blue-eyed people in spain like what
people are are making it seem as if she
so the fact that she she's no longer
going by hillary
and like like she's trying to be more
like people are claiming that she's
trying to be
more exotic and look more like oh she's
she's not just an american white girl
from boston like she's from spain and
like that's how people are well who
cares who gives a [ __ ] she should have a
[ __ ] emerson college
t-shirt on at all times and she needs to
you know
[ __ ] eat she's a bostonian right
so this whole scandal thing it has
actually
caused her to step away from social
media
and also she has lost brand sponsor or
partnerships
that's crazy she's getting almost semi
cancelled for this
semi cancelled also if i was her though
i would just be like
oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] it i'm american guys
uh i'm sorry
i [ __ ] up and i shouldn't have done
that even if it's like maybe i don't try
to cover it up or something
here's where i'm confused right so like
let's say
uh white people can't claim spanish
if they're not or americans can't claim
i don't know i thought spain was white
but then what if a asian kid grew up in
spain are they not allowed to
claim spanish i guess not because that
doesn't make any sense
that's yeah you're right they can't it
would make sense if she's not a citizen
i guess and it's like why would you
claim that you're not even like a
national
like like yeah but then for her she was
like well i grew up i vacationed there
my entire life why can't i
why can't this culture be part of my
culture if it was something i grew up
with
i get that i get i get why people are
pissed because it's like i have no
business calling myself a hawaiian local
um
and even if i go there and i have family
there and friends there and i love the
culture like i will never
claim that but so she's she's saying she
doesn't claim it like she always tells
the people that she's from boston and
she's american or whatever it's just a
tabloid
two instances where her own husband
refers to her as like my
my wife is from spain and so a lot of
people are grabbing on to that
oh it's confusing what the [ __ ] like why
is he claiming yeah
he should know where you're born get
wrong all the [ __ ] time pay attention
like i got a [ __ ] ice cream cake for
five years in a row like they don't
three years in a row you know so it's
like i get
where he [ __ ] yeah husband words is
not evidence yeah like i said
you can't fight the husband i think you
anything he would be like oh her
birthday uh
[ __ ] i don't know her birthday don't
quote him
wait i thought you were spanish haven't
you been saying that
i thought you were spanish what you
[ __ ] idiot what if he's the one
[ __ ] all this up like they call him
and they do the interviews
yeah my spanish wife yeah he goes honey
i'm not [ __ ] spanish i'm from boston
baby i can't understand spanish yeah
like how many times have both of you
been like
tiff when you grew up in mexico yeah and
she's like i didn't [ __ ] grow up in
mexico
right here is alec baldwin that's that's
who we should be getting mad at
stop giving [ __ ] up information your
wife isn't spanish and stop yelling at
your poor kid on the phone
you